Good animation
Bad animation
New
Old
Digital
Cel
Animation is an essential part of anime
WHOA! No FuCKiNg wAy!
When it's bad, it will be forever etched in our minds no matter how good the source material may be,
But when done right it can add so much magic to the anime experience
That you just have to sit back in awe and wonder...
WOW,
How could anyone achieve such beautiful fluid imagery?
With this video,
I wanted to just have a casual unstructured discussion about animation and anime
How it's evolved over the years,
Our general perception of it,
And where it could possibly go in the future
Now you may be thinking,
"Gigguk [Senpai], what makes you a qualified authority in animation?
Have you studied it,
Or can you name every animator who worked on every cut in the most recent episode of 'Bill and Ted's Shounen Adventures'?"
Unfortunately no,
But I will have you know that I have a pair of working eyes,
And more importantly,
I am officially certified in one of these
[Explosion]
hahahahahaha HAHAHAHAHA AH HAAHAHAHAHA
[Epic Music]
Let's start with a very basic background lesson on animation techniques used in anime
Mainly that of limited animation versus
SSSSSS
*tAKe My brEAth aWay*
Sakuga
Limited animation comes from a need to save time and money from production
'cause, as we all know in anime,
Deadlines are tight and budgets are even tighter.
If you look at most scenes in an anime series,
You will actually see that there is not much movement at all.
A lot of the times it's characters being completely static just moving their mouths which isn't that hard to pull off.
Here let me show you.
Take this frame from No Game No Life
All we want to do is to have Sora say a line,
"I eat ass" (Aka: demonetization)
So what we can do to achieve this is we need three frames,
A closed mouth
A half open mouth
And an open mouth.
So what I can do is I can take some examples from my library of anime mouths,
Edit them so the lighting fits,
Key in the frames
And now we can make him talk.
Sora: I eat ass.
Now let's make this shot a bit more dynamic by adding some camera movement, and WoO look at this!
Sora: (In the background) "I eat ass."
I'm an animator now!
Look at--Look at this smooth animation.
Sora: (In the background) "I eat ass."
That's right chums,
I don't just talk about anime
Sora: (In the background) "I eat ass."
I *AM* ANIME.
On the other end of the spectrum,
You have these moments or scenes where the animation quality increases dramatically.
Everything becomes so much more alive and expressive, and you think,
"Oh yeah, that's the money shot!
That's the budget!
This isn't just smooth,
This is *JAZZ* smooth.
This isn't just beautiful,
This is,
B - E - A - U - TI - FUL!
This isn't just fluid,
This is gender flui--
*lolz*
This is called,
SSSSSS
*tAKe My brEAth aWay*
Sakuga
And if you think about it,
The reason it exists makes sense because with the very limited budget and productive schedule a typical anime series has,
You'd want to focus most of your time and money on the important scenes ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Where extra effort and attention is needed,
As these are the parts the viewers will remember and you definitely want to leave a lasting impression ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
So next time you see one of these scenes you can now think to yourself,
Wow.
Such
Sakuga
It's these portions that stick in our minds when we think of good animation
Because the show can look like, absolute...
DOG SHIT
But if you have a few good moments of animation it may mask the fact that 90% of your show
Actually looks like crap,
A special technique known as the Studio Pierrot Special.
The first real question I want to pose is,
How do we actually define good animation?
Which sounds like a stupid obvious question, but stick with me here.
Unlike graphics and video games
Or CGI and movies
There is not one pinnacle that we are heading towards and can set a benchmark against.
We are not aiming for true immersion with photorealistic details.
I mean, this is animation.
The whole point of animation is that it is NOT real.
Sure most of the time we can collectively agree, which animation looks better.
Like if you watch an average show,
Let's say, 'All You Need is a Sister'
[It's actually, 'A Sister's All You Need' but whatever]
And you're like,
"Alright.
Okay, this is adequate.
It's not blowing my mind, but it's definitely doing the job it needs to do."
And then you pop in 'Red Line' and it's just like,
"Wow 'Red Line'.
Why not buy my eyes dinner first before trying to FuCK them...
Please."
"Ooh, 'Red Line'!
Okay.
Well my eyes don't normally put down a first date, but God you just look so good right now!
Okay, well now you're just pushing too hard and now I'm gonna have to file a sexual assault claim."
We can break it down to more frames of animation or more movement and fluidity on screen,
But honestly who's to say that the sensation overload of 'Red Line' has,
"GOODER ANIMATION" (-Gigguk 2017)
Than the ethereal photo realistic art style of Makoto Shinkai's works
Or the detailed expresive character animation in Yamada's "A Silent Voice"
When we get to animation of this level,
Becomes less a concrete metric we can judge against,
And more the personal bias and interpretation of the viewer watching it.
Going back to video games,
We can look at some graphics and think,
"Wow I almost can't tell the difference between this and real-life!
This is jaw-dropping!"
And in anime, you can look at a cut and say,
"Wow! This is so smooth and realistic!
THIS is jaw-dropping!"
But is this more impressive than the way Masaaki Yuasa warps and distorts to convey an idea with his surrealism?
Or in Imaishi's in-your-face-louder-than-life-hard-hitting cuts
Which is the animation equivalent of twenty Sylvester Stallone's kicking you in the nutsack simultaneously?
And I know there's more thoughts put into graphics in video games and realism,
But please don't make this discussion about that.
I was trying to make a point.
I think it's important to note that something can be technically well animated,
But still look like SHIT for other reasons
And I don't think there is a better example of this than the Naruto-Pain fight
This fight has gone down in infamy as the
"Worst-best animated fight that people like to make fun of"
You might have seen the still frames floating around with people like
"EH HEH
Look at his stupid face.
Isn't this such bad animation?
EHEHEHEHEHEHE-"
ACTUALLY NO
I can freeze frame in a random clip
Of you talking to make you look like an ugly motherfucker trying to suck DICK, but that doesn't mean you permanently look like that
PROBABLY
Animation is meant to be judged in motion and technically speaking
this fight is very well animated if we look at and actually badly
animated fight like this it looks like a goddamn circus performance. "He-Hey look. It's two stick figures trying ballet!"
The choreography is awful, there's like three frames of animation sometimes. It's so bad they're playing *music* couldn't even save it, but
Fuck playing *music*! What do we do?! WHAT THE FUCK DO WE DO?!
Then we go back to the pain fight, if everything is so fluid and expressive, I mean look at this!
THIS is good animation. My problem with it, (it) is that it looks fucking stupid.
I'm sure the intent was to have the character's warped and distorted
Enphasizing the intense emotions that the characters are feeling
But, I think in the process of trying to dial up the intensity to 11 they overshot it by a bit. And by a bit
I mean they launched it into the fucking
Stratosphere. So what we are left with is a wacky,
Cartoony, Looney Tunes brawl in what should be one of the most titular fight in the entire series
I mean I could seriously just add some Looney Tunes sound effects, and it would not feel out of place at all
[Lol, it doesn't feel out of place]
Not saying that going off model and a bit crazy with your animation is bad
If this was seen as something like "Ping Pong the animation" I'd be highly impressed, but in the context of the series
It's so ridiculous
It takes the viewer out of the experience rather than enhancing it. A complete opposite to say Konosuba (haven't seen it either) season two's
Animation here the characters constantly go off model looks stupid and wacky
And it works because this is a comedy
Anime. It helps add character and enhances the comedy in the series the next thing I want to touch on is how the quality of
Animation improves and can improve as time goes on
I mean, that makes sense right? Just look at a show like Soul Eater
Which is eight years old now and as you can see it just--it just looked terrible and dated
I mean we can obviously tell that this was made years ago with far inferior
Animation and I'm not even sure what no-name animated this now go forward five years with Soul Eater
Same studio same characters
And as you can see the noticeable improvement in animation is just...
unbelievable. Aside from the evolution of our Styles and character designs
I think in general with the average quality of animation does improve as time goes on and--this is just a guess--
But I think it's possible because there is an increased number of tools available
And more talent in the industry now to make things look better
Overall with the constraints anime has. If we take a much older show like for example
(:^ couldn't understand title) which is just the pinnacle of production values of the time. If you take this scene here and look really
carefully, and I mean look REALLY carefully, you may notice that to create the illusion of movement
They are just physically moving the camera and you know as cheap little tricks like this that can take you out of an experience
Because aside from this one thing the show is pretty much perfect in every other way
Invisible guy: "THERE'S WAR GOING ON! EVEN DINOSAURS ARE HERE! AND THEN YOU chose an arrow
A SWORD UNBELIEVABLY DULL I DON'T KNOW HOW WE GOT SEPARATED BUT I STILL THINK WE ARE ONE PERSON."
Anime dude: "We die together?"
Invisible daddy: "probably"
Overeactive dude: "NO! It can't be true!" Invisible daddy: "I'm not joking."
Now you see the tools that are available today
And it's like a whole new fucking playground to play with. I remember when Attack on Titan first aired (JAEGER)
And I was just in all the innovative use of the dynamic camera movements which I don't remember being integrated before in a TV series
So consistently--wait a minute
AH (MY EYES)
Which I'm sure would be much harder to do without the aid of computers in the era of cell animation
And if you compare what was possible before to what is now with the integration of computerized tools and digital
Composition. Well, I think Ghazis wing said it best: "You certainly got SEXY"
But as I talked about before, there is no pinnacle of animation. If we are talking about the best of the best--those sweet sweet
SSSSSS *TAKE MY FUCKING BREATH AWAY*
SAKUGA moments.
There are still moments--5, 10, 20 years old that still hold up to this day.
There are moments in Akira or old Ghibli films that still kick the ass of 90% of anime coming out today
Even some of the films. That's because these moments give an opportunity for the talent behind them to really shine and the biggest difference with
These tools and the bigger budgets is that it makes it easier for the talents behind the show to do what they want to do
And without that talent it means nothing. I know I've made an offhand joke about
Sakuga being the budget shot and while more time and money certainly doesn't hurt more budget does not necessarily mean better animation and
Vice-versa. Handshakers  this year was possibly the prettiest looking car crash
I've ever seen. It's like someone ate a whole pack of Skittles
Vomiting on screens started filming it while violently shaking the camera
it is a
Fucking mess. From a technical standpoint the production was very ambitious with the complex shots and highly stylized aesthetics
They were trying to put off and because of this, it's the perfect exsample of what happens when a bunch of guys plays around with these
tools and a budget without the talent to make it work.
And now a brief word on CG
That was it. I think what I was trying to get out here is that animation is kind of important to anime--
whaaaAAAAA-
We appreciate good animation
But simply saying something looks good doesn't do justice the huge variety of skill and talent out there on display
and I hope even if you're a more casual viewer you can at least appreciate the visual arts that goes into crafting the
Experience that you get how much animation can add that it can leave you in awe or how much you can detract from the experience
if done incorrectly
Since while now anime is as popular as ever with more of it than ever before and the art style ever evolving
It's important to remember that
how much tools improved to help artists or how big the industry grows and how much money is thrown into our projects
Nothing can ever, and will EVER replace a great artistic eye and raw talent because if that's the case
Then the pinnacle of animation has already been reached because WHOO that's right baby look at this lift laughs animation look at them!
OH GOD THAT'S WHAT SAKUGA COULD BE WITH SUCH PERFECTION
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed that video
Thank you very much this month to:
and everyone else on patreon for helping to support me for this month and making this video possible
For anyone is Singapore. I will be attending AFA there this weekend
So, uh, if you're there and you see me milling about feel free to come say hi
I probably won't be doing a meet-up this time since I'm going completely on a whim
But you can follow me on my Twitter to see what I'm up to you
And I see if I have any plans or what I'm doing then so... yeah
Not any more updates for me today so until then I've been Gigguk, and I will see you all next time (Subscribe and go to his Patreon! I'm never doing subtitles again, this was too tiring. Peace out!)